later this month way mo a company that's
owned by Google is going to introduce
their new self-driving minivans we've
been hearing about this stuff it's going
to happen now Google has assured the
public that they've worked out all the
kinks and that these new driverless vans
are completely safe however this is true
there have been persistent rumors that
earlier tests of the self-driving
minivans were a complete disaster now
Google has obviously tried to keep test
footage of these self-driving vans under
wraps we got a hold of footage from
several of the road tests take a look
[Music]
little accident there which isn't great
and that kind of thing can happen now
here we go this is going to go better
and then oh that's not so good that kind
of thing can happen you don't get too
upset oh he's going it's a good sign
he's doing well and
it's too bad and then
so going on car seems to be doing very
well and that stuff
that's just stupid I apologize for that
oh that's very good a new to stop at a
red light it's very good when a car
knows to stop at a red light because
that's a sign all right Eric I'm not
even touching any of your buildings it
seems to be doing enough I guess some
fog rolled in that's good
why and then here we go Oh seems to be
going bird
[Applause]
[Music]
you